if Greek and Roman mythology something
you studied read about Oh perhaps just
something you enjoy and it's very likely
the one-eyed giant figure that is the
Cyclops is something you're more than
familiar with I know for me growing up
the Cyclops always stuck out more than
other creatures but that might just be
because I found a giant with one eye in
the middle of its face a bit weird and
honestly quite disturbing before we go
any further there is one thing I'd like
to discuss and it's something I've
certainly thought about for a while and
that is the collective or the plural
term for a Cyclops when I was younger I
always just referred to them as
cyclopses but that isn't correct so when
I looked into it further it appears that
it's something people have been debating
for some time and there are some quite
interesting ideas to say the least these
can range anywhere from a pack of
Cyclops to a herd and even cyclope in
some cases which to me just sounds like
a one-eyed octopus the actual term that
most people seem to agree on when
referring to multiple Cyclops is
Cyclopes and that's what I'll be
referring to them as for the remainder
of this video the word Cyclops itself
when translated roughly means circle
eyed or round I'd which of course refers
to the giant eye that sits in the middle
of its forehead now as for the origins
of the Cyclopes and they were the
children of Uranus and Gaia making them
brothers to the hecatomb Crees and the
titans according to the Greek poet
Hesiod along with the Heckert encrease
the Cyclopes were seen as monstrous by
their siblings and their father and when
the titans overthrew their father Uranus
Cronus then imprisoned both the Hecate
on queries and the Cyclopes in the
darkest pits of Tartarus and placed a
dragon outside to ensure that they would
never escape as to why he would do this
there are several potential explanations
they could have been scared of the
Cyclopes and what they were capable of
and they could have also shared their
fall as the same or maybe they just
didn't like the fact that they were
different from them whatever the reason
was they would rather throw their
brothers into Tartarus than rule the
earth with them
the hecatomb Crees in the Cyclopes
remained in Tartarus until they heard a
voice from above asking them for their
assistance
this was the voice of Zeus who told them
that if they help the Olympians defeat
the Titans then he would free them and
they could live normal lives on earth
well as normal as a one-eyed Giants life
can get they accepted Zeus's offer and
when the war was over the Cyclopes and
the Hecate encrease were set free where
they would act as the craftsmen and
guardians to the gods and their secrets
Hesiod referred to three Cyclopes by
name Argos bronty's and stare appease
whom he considered to be the children of
Uranus single and the craftsman to
Olympus they would often be depicted by
their Forge as their names were closely
linked to blacksmithing and masonry
pretty much every trinkets artifact
weapon or piece of armor used by the
gods came from either the Cyclopes or
Hephaestus the Greek poet callimachus
described the Cyclopes as the helpers of
Hephaestus the noise emitting from
volcanoes was often explained as the
Cyclopes and Hephaestus working at their
Forge they also created Zeus's
Thunderbolt Poseidon's trident and even
Hades helmet of Darkness all three of
these creations arguably contributed to
their success and the dethroning of the
titans Zeus's Thunderbolt is an
interesting point of discussion because
all three brothers came together each
given an element that reflected their
name Argos the bright on the vivid added
brightness bronty's the Thunderer added
thunder and stare appease the lightning
uh added lightning and thus Zeus's
iconic Thunderbolt was created
they also made Artemis's moon bow and
the Sun bow of Apollo which is quite
ironic when we look at the play al
castis written by the Greek poet
Euripides in this play Apollo is so
incensed that Zeus had struck down his
son Asclepius over Thunderbolts that he
then turned his attention to its
creators
rather than retaliate against his own
father Zeus Apollo instead killed the
Cyclopes presumably with the bow that
they created this of course solves
nothing
and only served to further anger Zeus
who sent Apollo to Thessaly where he
would be the servant of King Admetus for
an entire year
Zeus having one quite fond of the
Cyclopes and wanting to remain loyal
because of their assistance then
traveled to the underworld where he
resurrected them along with Apollo's
fallen son Asclepius there are some
versions of this myth that state the
Cyclopes were never resurrected instead
their spirits roam the volcano of Mount
Etna in Sicily Euripides also wrote a
play titled Cyclops from which he drew
inspiration from homer and his Odyssey
in this play there is only one Cyclops
who lives on Mount Etna this depiction
differs quite drastically from that of
Hesiod the Cyclops here is an angry
cannibalistic and rather stupid
character who ends up being blinded and
punished for not respect in the Rite of
hospitality this kind of satirical take
on the Cyclopes was quite common as a
response to homers story which at the
time was criticized by quite a few so
now we move on to perhaps the most
famous story feature in a cyclops the
encounter between Odysseus and
Polyphemus in book 9 of Homer's Odyssey
similar to the stories we've just
discussed a decision his men land on the
island of the Cyclops just off the coast
of Sicily Homer described the Cyclopes
as giant one-eyed shepherds who were the
children of Poseidon and an enthusiast
and his men come across a cave full of
provisions and being in desperate need
they decide to enter little did they
know that this cave belongs to the
Cyclops Polyphemus who had just returned
home with his cattle Odysseus and his
men would not find the hospitality that
they were expecting as Polyphemus
blocked the entrance of the cave of a
giant stone and then ate two of his men
the next morning he ate two more men and
left to tend his cattle which left the
dices and his men to hatch a plan of
escape when the Cyclops returned home
that evening he
again eight two more of a deceases men
making it six in total
Odysseus then offered his cap to some
wine but this wine had not been diluted
and the Cyclops was soon drunk he would
then ask her to cease for his name
promising to give him a gift if he
answered
- which Odysseus responded my name is
nobody and Polyphemus then promised that
he would eat nobody last when the
Cyclops passed out
Odysseus took a wooden stake that he had
hardened over the fire and drove it
through Polyphemus his eye blind in him
in the process
Polyphemus screamed in agony and alerted
the other Cyclopes
but his calls for help were ignored as
he screamed nobody has heard me nobody
has blinded me leaving the other
Cyclopes confused and unsure as to what
had truly happened the next morning he
let out his sheep and closed the
entrance to the cave once again not
wanting the men to escape
Odysseus and his men however had tied
themselves to the underside of the Sheep
as the blinded Cyclops would never see
them once out of the cave Odysseus and
his men returned to their ship and set
sail but not before Odysseus made the
mistake of boasting that he had escaped
the Cyclops telling Polyphemus his true
name so he may know the man who bested
him this would ultimately backfire
horrendously as Polyphemus told his
father of the man who blinded him
Poseidon then rained down rocks upon his
ship which they were barely able to
escape I know whatever I cover Greek
myths and stories there are quite a few
people who also like to hear about some
of the Roman iterations so in response
to this story by Homer the Roman poet
Virgil mentions Polyphemus in what he
considered to be a sequel to homers
story in his very own epic poem the
Aeneid in this story the hero Aeneas and
his crew land on the same island
shortly after escape in the Trojan War
they come across a man from Ithaca who
were stranded on the island during
Odysseus's expedition the man tells them
of Odysseus and his story and how he was
able to escape they then see a one-eyed
giant using a tree as a walking stick
lead in his cattle to the shore
where he washes his bloody eye socket
letting out groans of pain that can be
heard all across the island when
Polyphemus spots the men in the ship he
begins to give chase but in EEOC's crew
and the man from Ithaca set sail leaving
Polyphemus and the other Cyclopes
screaming in a distance
Polyphemus does also appear in somewhat
of a love story which we can assume took
place before he was blinded this
particular story was told by several
poets including Ovid and many
playwrights that followed with george
frideric handel telling the story in his
musical a kiss and Galatea first
performed in 1718 Polyphemus fell in
love with a nymph named Galatea but with
the Cyclops not really being described
as the most respectful or even pleasant
individual his advances were rejected
instead Galatea fell in love of a
handsome man named a kiss
and so Polyphemus did what any decent
man or Cyclops would do in this given
situation he accepted the woman he loved
didn't feel the same and just moved on
now I'm just messing with you he took a
giant boulder and squashed a kiss
because there's no competition if you
just squash them of boulders the blood
of a kiss would then form a river with
the same name and he would become the
spirit of that river so the whole me
squash your lover you marry me now
didn't really work for Polyphemus
because he is what we call in
mythological terms a one-eyed twit
okay so maybe that's not a technical
term but you get the point
Hesiod Cyclopes pretty cool craftsman
Polyphemus big angry man-eating dum-dum
the Cyclops is a creature mentioned by
countless Greek and Roman poets and
these depictions can vary from brilliant
craftsmen to cannibalistic Giants and in
some cases big fat oaths who serve no
other purpose but to make us laugh it is
quite interesting to see such varying
descriptions Hesiod believed them to be
quite intelligent blacksmiths and
craftsmen who were civilized and
obedient
whereas Homer portrays them as wild
cannibals who have no laws and who live
high in the mountains with little
loyalty to even their own kind
the idea of a one-eyed creature or
monster is definitely not unique to
ancient Greece and Rome we see one-eyed
creatures across many other cultures
with one of my favorites being Balor the
one-eyed form or Aeon of Irish mythology
whose eye causes untold destruction in
chaos when opened
so pretty much Cyclops from the x-men
overall my opinion in the Cyclopes has
changed quite a bit over the years
having seen them in movies when I was
younger I honestly just believe them to
be evil monsters but there is definitely
more than meets the eye feel free to let
me know what you think in the comments
below which version of the Cyclops had
you heard of and which one do you prefer
monster or craftsman let me know in the
comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
you